and camus who might be my all-time
you know great uh lighthouse so to speak
in terms of being a man of conscious
you know he joined the communist party
and for a lot of people in the states
you hear
oh you joined the communist party so i
need to hear it so all you need he was a
communist all you need to know
he joined the communist party because
they were the main ones fighting the
fascists in france and
other locations and he took nazism as in
many others of course
very very very seriously he wasn't some
committed communist but this was just
his
mechanism to take on uh you know be part
of the underground and vichy france and
so on and so forth
so he had the quote which is ascribed to
him
which is kind of a misquote howard zinn
is the one who actually said it that
it is a job of thinking people not to be
on the side of the executioners
and he very much felt if you read his uh
speech when he won the nobel prize i
forget
in the 50s where he goes it's basically
the job of writers
to keep civilization from destroying
himself i don't think i'm ever going to
be
a man on the level of camus and what
he's accomplished but i think
that vision of it is the job of
writers to be the conscience and to
point out
uh this is the leftism at its best when
you know giving voice to the voiceless
when you have the machine of the state
crushing and marginalizing people
and they might not be educated literate
or have any power at all
some he's the guy who's like you are
ruining
humans these humans matter and i'm not
going to let you look the other way
and act like you don't know what you're
doing
you